credit-card debt is just become a way of
life in our country in fact credit cards
weren't even available about 30 years
ago and you're right you know we we use
it as a way to extend our income so when
I talk to families and to consumers at
large I'm a big believer that we have to
teach our young kids you know as
teenagers how to use credit cards wisely
in other words paying it off on a
monthly basis understanding how fees and
interest work a lot of people were not
educated about this and what we're
finding through our studies is that
teenagers you know 13 to 18 years old
already Oh on average $300 to an
individual or an institution so even our
young you know kids are using these
credit cards and so parents really need
to to work with them and make it a
discipline to pay it off monthly and and
similar to like it to teaching your kid
how to drive you want them to do it
under your roof before they leave home
and getting a lot of trouble
you